Chris Brown slapped with a temporary  restraining order by ex Karrueche Tran a  judge granted trance request after she  accused Brown of abusing and threatening  her et has the court docs in them Tran  says the singer punched her twice in the  stomach and pushed her down the stairs  years ago she also claims that earlier  this month Brown threatened to kill her  and makes me I don't be listening to all  this bull man on Tuesday Chris shared  this cryptic message on Instagram what  other people of us had don't let them do  they doing on gentlemen  twenty-seven-year-old has been ordered  to stay a hundred yards away from his ex  and surrender any firearms until their  March ninth hearing et has reached out  to Brown's lawyer for comment